Are you familiar with mistletoe IV therapy? Yes, very familiar with that. So I have a provider here that does that. So mistletoe IV therapy is typically giving you can give mistletoe IV or mistletoe injections into your belly.
The benefit of mistletoe injections is you can do it from home. The benefit for mistletoe IV or getting much higher dose mistletoe. It's stimulated in immune reactions. What really what it is. So some people have very good results from that.
So, you know, there's, is there downsides to it? You know, I don't really think so. I mean, I know people that have reacted negatively to it, but you'll know that it's not like it's like you're, it's going to hurt you, you know, long term, but you'll they just had to stop taking it. So, but there are other than that. No.
Also does Benagene lower sugar about other things. Benagene, I don't think that Benagene is going is not going to be a strong.
Blue coast inhibitor in the bloodstream. So if you did, let's say I'm a cometer, tested your glucose was, I don't know, let's say, you know, 87 and you took some Benagene, is it going to decrease your glucose, I don't, I don't believe so. I didn't see anything on it lowering blood glucose.
So it pushes the Krebs cycle is really what it does. So it decreases the benefit reason why Benagene can be beneficial for cancer is that cancers that are driven through the warberg effect, which is so glucose breaks down through glycolysis, you remember high school biology. And then you end up with
producing lactic acid and lactic acid can be a fuel for cancer. If the cancer is very hungry and can't wait for the
Seedle Coenzyne to go into the Krebs cycle and Benagene helps push that function into the Krebs cycle so that you don't end up feeding cancer through glycolysis as easily.
So, there is a huge benefit to Benagene.
I just interviewed one of the founders of terobiologicals in a kid that cut its clinic live podcast. I don't think Dustin had has published that live yet, but he can't even talk about cancer.
The Benagene actually the first studies with Benagene was on.
Oxal on it's because Benagene is oxaloacetate, which is one of the components of the Krebs cycle.
Some of the first studies on on oxaloacetate and Benagene was using them with astrocytomas because it could block the astrocytomas feed off of glutamine.
So, long story short, they had to pull the FDA made them pull that study, even though they had published studies showing that that would be beneficial, made them pull everything off of their website that showed that Benagene and oxaloacetate was beneficial for cancer.
And so that's going to be exciting. It probably will take a couple of years to get published. They did another study on oxaloacetate and breast cancer, which have to use higher dose oxaloacetate so Benagene is the lower dose of oxaloacetate and then the company has an oxaloacetate CFS because they did multiple studies on oxaloacetate and chronic fatigue syndrome.
And that's the only thing that they can publish on their website right now.
Is 250 milligrams dose a day, a good daily dose? Yes, that's a good daily dose of that. The oxaloacetate CFS is even a higher dose of that.
And that's the benefit of that is giving it a higher dose per pill soon. I'm going to take so many pills.